help
so i get like that and if he can't move
he says
even if he doesn't know my name uh could
you do it a bit less
if i go
he can't do it oh i don't know if i'll
he's off a bit
it's not doing his ego any good because
he doesn't want to say it he doesn't
want to admit that he can't do the
technical move
so i've got to help him to reduce his
ego
so if he can't move he has to
could you please yeah tell me and i'll
go oh all right how's that
does that mean
so so so
that's my teaching cytosim she never
touched
and you will all be individual teachers
and see and you will teach how you wish
to teach so your aikido is the best
because it's your if you don't
all right so if you can't do anything
today
then
um
if you can't end today then just say
a little bit less please but just do
like 10 percent at a time if you can
until they can do it but it's still a
struggle
so that's the way i like to teach